The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right.
Today is all about the
predecessor problem, which
is a problem we've certainly
talked about implicitly
with, say, binary search trees.
You want to be able to
insert and delete into a set,
and compute the predecessor
and successor of any given key.
So maybe define that formally.
And this is not
really our first,
but it is an example of
an integer data structure.
And for whatever
reason, I don't brand
hashing as an integer
data structure,
just because it's its own beast.
But in particular, today,
I need to be a little more
formal about the models of
computation we're allowing--
or I want to be.
In particular, because, in the
predecessor problem, which is,
insert, delete,
predecessor, successor,
there are actually lower bounds
that say you cannot do better
than such and such.
With hashing, there aren't
really any lower bounds,
because you can do
everything in constant time
with high probability.
So I mean, there are
maybe some lower bounds
on deterministic hashing.
That's harder.
But if you allow randomization,
there's no real lower bounds,
whereas predecessor, there is.
And in general,
predecessor problem--
the key thing I
want to highlight
is that we're maintaining
here a set of--
the set is called s
of n elements, which
live in some universe, U--
just like last time.
When you insert, you can
insert an arbitrary element
of the universe.
That probably shouldn't be an
s, or it will get thrown away.
But the key thing is that
predecessor and successor
operate not just on
the [INAUDIBLE] in s,
but you can give it any key.
It doesn't have to be in there.
And it will find the
previous key that is in s,
or the next key that is in s.
So predecessor is
the largest key
that is less than or equal
to x that's in your set.
And successor is the
smallest that is larger--
of course, if there is one.
So those are the kinds of
operations we want to do.
Now, we know how to do all of
this n log n time, no problem,
with binary search trees,
in the comparison model.
But I want to introduce two
more, say, realistic models
of computers, that ignore
the memory hierarchy,
but think about
regular RAM machines--
random access machines--
and what they can really do.
And it's a model we're going
to be working on for the next,
I think, five lectures.
So, important to
set the stage right.
So these are models for
integer data structures.
In general, we have
a unifying concept,
which is a word of
information, a word of data,
a word of memory.
It's used all over the
place-- a word of input.
A word is the machine
theoretic sense,
not like the linguistic sense.
It's going to be
a w-bit integer.
And so this defines the
universe, which is--
I'm going to assume they're
all unsigned integers.
So this is 2 to the w minus one.
Those are all the
unsigned integers
you can represent with w-bits.
We'll also call this number,
2 to the w, little u.
That is the size of the
universe, which is capital U.
So this matches
notation from last time.
But I'm really highlighting how
many bits we have, which is w.
Now, here's where
things get interesting.
I'm going to get to
a model called a word
RAM, which is what you
might expect, more or less.
But before I get there I
want to define something
called transdichotomous RAM--
tough word to spell.
It just means bridging
a dichotomy-- bridging
two worlds, if you will.
RAM is a random access machine.
I've certainly mentioned
the word RAM before.
But now we're going to get a
little more precise about it.
So in general, in the
RAM, memory is an array.
And you can do random
access into the array.
But now, we're going to say,
the cells of the memory--
each slot in that array--
is a word.
Everything is
going to be a word.
Every input-- all these
x's are going to be words.
Everything will be a word.
And in particular, the things
in your memory are words.
Let's say you have s of them.
That's your space bound.
In general, in
transdichotomous RAM,
you can do any operation
that reads and writes
a constant number
of words in memory.
And in particular, you can do
random access to that memory.
But in particular, we use
words to serve as pointers.
Here's my memory of words.
Each of them is w bits--
so s of them, from, I
guess, 0 to s minus one.
And if you have, like,
the number 3 here,
that can be used as a pointer
to the third slot of memory.
One, two, three.
You can use numbers as
indexes into memory.
So that's what I mean by,
words serve as pointers.
So particularly, you can
implement a pointer machine,
which-- no surprise--
but for this to work, we
need a lower bound on w.
This implies w has to be at
least log of the space bound.
Otherwise, you just can't
index your whole memory.
And if you've got s minus 1
things, this 2 to the w minus 1
better be at least s minus 1.
So we get this lower bound.
So in particular, presumably, s
is at least your problem size,
n.
If you're trying to
maintain n items,
you've got to store them.
So w is at least log n.
Now, this relation is
essentially a statement
bridging two worlds.
Namely, you have,
on the one hand,
your model of computation, which
has a particular word size.
And in reality, we think of that
as being 32 or 64 or maybe 128.
Some fancy operations
on Intel machines,
you can do 128-bit or so.
And then there's
your problem size,
which we think of as an input.
Now, this is relating the two.
It's a little weird.
I guess you could say it's just
a limitation for a given CPU.
There's only certain
problems you can solve.
But theoretically, it
makes a lot of sense
to relate these two.
Because if you're
in a RAM, and you've
got to be able to
index your data,
you need at least
that many bits just
to be able to talk
about all those things.
And so the claim is,
basically, machines
will grow to
accommodate memory size.
As memory size grows,
you'll need more bits.
Now, in reality, there's
only about 2 to 256--
what do you call
them-- particles
in the known universe.
So word size probably
won't get that much bigger.
Beyond 256 should be OK.
But theoretically,
this is a nice way
to formalize this claim
that word sizes don't
need to get too big unless
memories get gigantic.
So it may seem weird at
first, but it's very natural.
And all real world machines
have big enough words
to accommodate that.
Word size could be bigger,
and that will give you,
essentially, more parallelism.
But it should be
at least that big.
All right.
Enough proselytizing.
That's the transdichotomous RAM.
The end.
And the word RAM is
a specific version
of the transdichotomous
RAM, where
you restrict the operations
to c-like operations.
These are sort of the standard--
they're instructions
on, basically,
all computers, except a few
risk architectures don't have
multiplication and division.
But everything else
is on everything.
So these are the operators,
unless I missed one, in c.
They're all in Python,
and pick your--
most languages.
You've got integer
arithmetic, including mod.
You've got bitwise and,
bitwise or, bitwise x
or, bitwise negation, and
shift left, and shift right.
These we all view as
taking constant time.
They take one or two integer
inputs-- words as inputs.
They can compute an answer.
They write out another word.
Of course, there's also random
access-- array dereference,
I guess.
So that's the word RAM.
You restrict to
these operations.
Whereas transdichotomous
RAM, you
can do weird things, as
long as they only involve
a constant number of words.
Word RAM-- it's
the regular thing.
So this is basically
the standard model
that all integer data
structures use, pretty much.
If they don't use this
model, they have to say so.
Otherwise this model has become
accepted as the normal one.
It took several years
before people realized
that's a good model--
good enough to capture
pretty much everything we want.
The cool thing
about word RAM is,
it lets you do things
on w-bits in parallel.
You can take the and of
w-bits, pairwise, all at once.
So you get some speed up.
But it's a natural
generalization of something
like the comparison model.
Comparison model-- I guess
I didn't write those.
It's more operations-- less
than, greater than, and so on.
You can compare two
numbers in constant time,
get a Boolean output
via, say, subtraction,
and computing the sine.
And you think of comparisons
as taking constant time,
so why not all of these things?
Cool.
One more model-- this
is kind of a weird one.
It's called cell
probe model, which
is, we just count
the number of memory
reads and writes that we
need to do to solve a data
structure or a query.
Like, you you're
looking at predecessor,
and you just want to know,
how much of the data structure
do I have to read in order to be
able to answer the predecessor
problem?
How much do I have
to write out to do
an insertion, or whatever?
And so in this model,
computation is free.
And this is kind of like
the external memory model,
and the cache oblivious models.
There, we were
measuring how many block
reads and writes there are.
Here, our blocks are
actually our words.
So there is a bit of a relation,
except there's no real--
you can either think
of there being no cache
here, because
you're just reading
in a constant number of words,
doing something, spitting
stuff out.
Or in the cell probe
model, you could
imagine there being an infinite
cache for this operation,
but no cache from
operation to operation.
It's just, how much do I have
to [INAUDIBLE] information,
theoretically, to solve a
particular predecessor problem?
We'll deal with this
a lot in a couple
of lectures-- not quite yet.
This model is just
used for lower bounds.
It's not a realistic
model, because you
have to pay for computation
in the real world.
But if you can
prove that you need
to read at least a certain
number of words, then,
of course, you have to do at
least that many operations.
So it's nice for lower bounds.
In general, we have this
sort of hierarchy of models,
where this is the most
powerful, strongest,
and below cell probe, we
have transdichotomous RAM,
then word RAM, then--
just to fit it in context,
what we've been doing--
below that is pointer
machine, and below that
would be binary search tree.
I've mentioned before,
pointer machines
are more powerful than
binary search tree.
And of course, we can
implement a pointer machine
on a word RAM.
So we have these relations.
There are, of
course, other models.
But this is a quick picture
of models we've seen so far.
So now, we have this
notion of a word.
In the predecessor problem,
these elements are words.
They're w-bit integers,
universe-defined.
And we want to be able to
insert, delete, predecessor,
and successor over words.
So that's our challenge.
In the binary search
tree model, we
know the answer to this
problem is theta log n.
In general, any
comparison-based data structure,
you need theta log
n, in the worst case.
It's an easy lower bound.
But we're going to do better on
these other models in the word
RAM.
So here are some results.
First data structure is
called Van Emde Boas.
You might guess it
is by van Emde Boas--
Peter.
It actually has a
couple other authors
in some versions of
the papers, which
makes a little bit confusing.
But for whatever reason,
the data structure
is just named Van Emde Boas.
And it achieves log
w per operation.
I think I'll rewrite this.
This is log log u per operation.
But it requires u space.
So think of u space as
being, like, for every item
in the universe I store,
yes or no, is it in the set?
So that's a lot of space, unless
n and u are not too different.
But we can do better.
But the cool thing
is the running time.
This is really fast--
log log u.
If you think about,
for example--
I don't know-- the universe
being polynomial in n,
or even if the universe
is something like--
polynomial in n is
the same as this--
2 to the c log n.
You can go crazy and
say log to the c power--
so, like, 2 to the log
to the fifth power.
All those things,
you take log twice.
Then log log u becomes
theta log log n.
So as long as your word
size is not insanely large,
you're getting log
log n performance.
So in general, when, let's
say, w is is polylog n,
then we're getting this
kind of performance.
And I think on most computers,
w is polylogarithmic.
We said it has to
be at least log.
It's also, generally, not
so much bigger than log.
So log squared is probably
fine most of the time,
unless you have a
really small problem.
OK, so cool.
But the space is giant.
So how do we do
better than that?
Well, there's a
couple of answers.
One is that you can achieve
log w with high probability,
and order n space.
With a slight tweak, basically,
you combine Van Emde Boas
plus hashing, and you get that.
I don't actually know what the
reference is for this result.
It's been an exercise in
various courses, and so on.
I can talk more
about that later.
Then alternatively, there's
another data structure, which,
in many ways, is simpler.
It really embraces hashing.
It's called y-fast trees.
It achieves the same
bounds-- so log w
with high probability
and linear space.
It's basically just a hash
table with some cleverness.
So we'll get there.
Even though it's
simpler, we're going
to start with this structure.
Historically, this is
the way it happened--
Van Emde Boas, then y-fast
trees, which are by Willard.
And it'll be kind
of a nice finale.
There's another data structure
I want to talk about,
which is designed for the
case when w is very large--
much bigger than polylog n.
In that case, there's
something called fusion trees.
And you can achieve
log base w of n--
and, I guess, with high
probability and linear space.
The original fusion
trees are static.
And you could just do log base
w of n deterministic queries.
But there's a later
version that dynamic,
achieves this using hashing
for updates, insertions,
and deletions.
Cool.
So this is an
almost upside-down--
it's obviously
always an improvement
over just log base 2 of n.
But it's sometimes better and
sometimes worse than log w.
In fact, it kind of makes
sense to take the min of them.
When w is small, you
want to use log w.
When w is big, you want
to use log base w of n.
They're going to balance out
when w is 2 to the root log n--
something like that.
The easy thing is,
when these balance out
is when they're equal.
And that will be when this
is log n divided by log w.
So when log w equals
log n divided by log w--
let do that over here.
log w is log n over log w.
Then this is like saying
log squared w equals log n,
or log w is root log n.
So I was right. w is
2 to the root log in,
which is a weird quantity.
But the easy thing to
think about is this one--
log w is root log n.
And in that case, the running
time you get is root log n.
So it's always, at most, this.
And the worst case is when
these things are balanced,
or these two are the same, and
they both achieve root log n.
But if w is smaller or
larger than this threshold,
these structures will be
even better than root log n.
But in particular,
it's a nice way
to think about, oh, we're
doing sort of a square factor
better than binary search trees.
And we can do this high
probability in linear space.
So that's cool.
Turns out it's also
pretty much optimal.
And that's not at all
obvious, and wasn't
known for many years.
So there's a cell
probe lower bound.
So these are all in
the word RAM model--
all these results.
The first one actually kind of
works in the pointer machine.
I'll talk about that later.
This lower bound's a
little bit messy to state.
The bound is slightly
more complicated
than what we've seen.
But I'm going to restrict to
a special situation, which is,
if you have n polylog n space.
So this is a lower bound
on static predecessor.
All you need to do is solve
predecessor and successor,
or even just predecessor.
There's no inserts and deletes.
In that case, if you use lots of
space, like u space, of course,
you can do constant
time for everything.
You just store all the answers.
But if you want space that's
not much bigger than n--
in particular, if you wanted
to be able to do updates
in polylog, this
is the most space
you could ever hope to achieve.
So assuming that, which
is pretty reasonable,
there's a bound of the
min of two things--
log base w of n,
which is fusion trees,
and, roughly, log w,
which is Van Emde Boas.
But it's slightly
smaller than that.
Yeah, pretty weird.
Let me tell you
the consequences--
a little easier to think about.
Van Emde Boas is going to be
optimal for the kind of cases
we care about, which
is when w is polylog n.
And fusion trees are
optimal when w is big.
Square root log n log log n.
OK-- a little messy.
So there's this divided by
log of log w over log n.
If w is polylog n, then this
is just order log log n.
And so this cancels.
This becomes constant.
So in these situations, which
are the ones I mentioned over
here, w is polylog
n, which is when
we get log log n performance.
And that's kind of the
case we care about.
Van Emde Boas is the
best thing to do.
Turns out, this is
actually the right answer.
You can do slightly better.
It's almost an exercise.
You can tweak Van Emde Boas and
get this slight improvement.
But most word sizes, it
really doesn't matter.
You're not saving much.
Cool.
So other than that
little factor,
these are the right answers.
You have to know
about Van Emde Boas.
about fusion trees.
And so this lecture is
about Van Emde Boas.
Next lecture is
about fusion trees.
This result is from 2006
and 2007, so pretty recent.
So let's start a Van Emde Boas.
Yeah.
Let's dive into it.
I'll talk about
history a little later.
The central idea,
I guess, if you
wanted to sum up Van Emde
Boas in an equation, which
is something we very rarely
get to do in algorithms,
is to think about
this recurrence--
T of u is T of square
root of u plus order 1.
What does this solve to?
log log u.
All right, just
think of taking logs.
This is the same as
T of w equals T of w
over 2 plus order 1.
w is the word size.
And so this is log w.
It's the same thing.
If we could achieve
this recurrence, then--
boom-- we get our
bound of log w.
So how do we do it.
We split the universe
into root u clusters,
each of size root u.
OK, so, if here is our
universe, then I just
split every square
root of u items.
So each of these is root u long.
The number of them
is square root of u.
And then somehow,
I want to recurse
on each of these clusters.
And I only get to
recurse on one of them--
so a pretty simple idea.
Yeah.
So I'll talk about
how to actually do
that recursion in a moment.
Before I get there,
I want to define
a sort of hierarchical
coordinate system.
This is a new way of
phrasing it for me.
So I hope you like it.
If we have a word x, I
want to write it as two
coordinates-- c and i.
I'm going to use
angle brackets, so it
doesn't get too confusing. c
is which cluster you're in.
So this is cluster 0, cluster
1, cluster 2, cluster three.
i is your index
within the cluster.
So this is 0, 1, 2, 3, 4,
5-- up to root u minus 1
within this cluster.
Then 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5
up to root u minus 1
with in this
cluster-- so the i is
your index within the
cluster, like this,
and c is which
cluster you are in.
OK.
Pretty simple.
And there's easy
arithmetic to do this.
c is x integer divide root u.
And i is x integer mod root u.
I used Python notation here.
So fine, I think
you all know this--
pretty simple.
And if I gave you
c and i, you could
reconstruct x by just
saying, oh, well,
that's c times root u plus i.
So in constant time, you
can decompose a number
into its two coordinates.
That's the point.
In fact, it's much
easier than this.
You don't even
have to do division
if you think of
everything in binary,
which computers tend to do.
So the binary perspective
is that x is a word.
So it's a bunch of bits.
0, 1, 1, 0, 1, 0,
0, 1-- whatever.
Divide that bit sequence
in half, and then this part
is c, this part is i.
And if you assume that
w is a power of 2,
these two are identical.
If they're not a
power of 2, you've
got to round a little bit here.
It doesn't matter.
But you can use this definition
instead of this one either way.
So in this case, c is--
ooh, boy-- x shifted
right, w over 2, basically.
So this w over 2--
w over 2.
The whole thing is w bits.
So if I shift right, I get
rid of the low order bits,
if I want.
i is slightly more annoying.
But I can't do it
as an and with one
shifted left w over 2 minus 1.
That's probably
how you do it in c.
I don't know if
you're used to this.
But if I take it a 1 bit,
I shift it over to here,
and I subtract 1.
Then I get a whole
bunch of 1 bits.
And then you mask
with that bit pattern.
So I'm masking with 1, 1, 1, 1.
Then I'll just get
the low order bits.
Computers do the
super fast-- way
faster than integer division.
Because this is just
like routing bits around.
So this is easy to
do on a typical CPU.
And this will be much
faster than this code,
even though looks like
more operations, typically.
All right.
So fine.
The point is, I can
decompos x into c and i.
Of course, I can
also do the reverse.
This would be c shifted
left w over 2, ord with i.
It's a slight diversion.
Now, I can tell you
the actual recursion,
and then talk about
how to maintain it.
So we're going to define
a recursive Van Emde Boas
structure of size
u and word size w.
And what it's going
to look like is,
we have a bunch of clusters,
each of size square root of u.
So this represents the
first root u items.
This represents the
next root u items.
This represents the last
root u items, and so on.
So that's the obvious
recursion from this.
So this is going to
be a Van Emde Boas
structure of size root u.
And then we also
have a structure
up top, which is called
the summary structure.
And the idea is, it represents,
for each of these clusters,
is the cluster empty or not?
Does this cluster
have any items in it?
Yes or no.
If yes, then the
name of this cluster
is in the summary structure.
So notice, by this
hierarchical decomposition,
the cluster number
and the index are
valid names of items
within these substructures.
And basically we're going to use
the i part to talk about things
within the clusters.
And we're going to use the
c part to talk about things
within the summary structure.
They're both numbers between
0 and root u minus 1.
And so we get this perspective.
All right.
So formally, or some
notation, cluster i--
so we're going to have
an array of clusters.
It is Van Emde Boas thing
of size square root u,
and word size w over 2.
This is slightly weird,
because the machine, of course,
its word size remains w.
It doesn't get smaller
as you recurse.
We're not going to try
to spread the parallelism
around or whatever.
But this is just a
notational convenience.
I want to say the
word size conceptually
goes down to w over 2, so
that this definition still
makes sense.
Because as I look at a
smaller part of the word,
in order to divide it in
half, I have to shift right
by a smaller amount.
So that's the w that I'm
passing into the structure.
OK, and then v dot
summary is same thing.
It's also Van Emde Boa's
thing of size root u.
Then the one other clever idea,
which makes all of this work,
is that we store the minimum
element in v dot min.
And we do not store
it recursively.
So there's also one item here,
size 1, which is the min.
It's just stored
off to the side.
It doesn't live in
these structures.
Every other item
lives down here.
And furthermore, if one
of these is not empty,
there's also a
corresponding item up here.
This turns out to be crucial
to make a Van Emde Boas work.
And then v dot
max, we also need--
but it can be
stored recursively.
So just think of it
as a copy of whatever
the maximum element is.
OK, so in constant time,
we can compute the min
and compute the max.
That's good.
But then I claim also in log
w time-- log log u time--
we can do insert, delete,
predecessor, successor.
So let's do that.
This data structure--
the solution
is both simple and
a little bit subtle.
And so this will be
one of the few times
I'm going to write
explicit pseudocode-- say
exactly how to maintain
this data structure.
It's short code, which is good.
Each algorithm is
only a few lines.
But every line matters.
So I want to write them down
so I can talk about them.
And with this new
hierarchical notation,
I think it's even easier
to write these down.
Let's see how I do.
OK, so we'll start with
the successor code.
Predecessor is,
of course, metric.
And it basically has two cases.
There's a special case
in the beginning, which
is, if the thing you're
querying happens to be less
than the minimum of the
whole thing, then of course,
the minimum is the successor.
This has to be done specially,
because the min is not
stored recursively.
And so you've got
to check for the min
every single level
of the recursion.
But that's just constant time.
No big deal.
Then the interesting
things is, we
have recursions in both sides--
in both cases-- but only one.
The key is, we want
this recurrence--
T of u is 1 times T of
root u plus order 1.
That gives us log log u.
If there was a 2 here, we would
get log u, which is no good.
We want the one.
So in one case, we call
successor on a cluster.
In the other case,
we call successor
on the summary structure.
But we don't want to do both.
So let's just think about,
intuitively, what's going on.
We've got this--
I guess I can do it
in the same picture.
We've got this summary
and a bunch of clusters.
And let's say you want
to compute, what's
the successor of this item?
So via this
transformation, we compute
which cluster it lives in and
where it is within the cluster.
That's i.
So it's some item here.
Now, it could be the successor
is inside the same cluster.
Maybe there's an
item right there.
Then want to recurse in here.
Or it could be, it's
in some future cluster.
Let's do the first case.
If, basically, we are less than
the max of our own cluster,
that means that the
answer is in there.
Figure out what the max
is in this structure--
the rightmost item in s
that's inside this cluster c.
This is c.
If our index is less than the
max's index, then if we recurse
in here, we will find an answer.
If we're bigger than
the max, then we
won't find an answer down here.
We have to recurse
somewhere else.
So that's what we do.
If we're less than
the max, then we just
recursively find the successor
of our index within cluster c.
And we have to add
on the c in front.
Because successor
within this cluster
will only give an index
within the cluster.
And we have to prepend this
c part to give a global name.
OK, so that's case 1.
Very easy.
The other case is where we're
slightly clever, in some sense.
We say, OK, well, if there's no
successor within the cluster,
maybe it's in the next cluster.
Of course, that one might
be empty, in which case,
it's in the next cluster.
But that one might be empty,
so look at the next cluster.
We need to find, what is
the next non-empty cluster?
For that, we use the
summary structure.
So we go up to position c here.
We say, OK, what is the next
non-empty structure after c?
Because we know that's
going to be where
our answer lives for successor.
So that's going to
give us, basically,
a pointer to one of these
structures-- c prime, which--
all these guys are empty.
And so there's no
successor in there.
The successor is then the
min in this structure.
So that's all we do.
Compute the successor of c
in the summary structure.
And then, in that
cluster, c prime,
find the min, which
takes constant time,
and then prepend c prime to
that to get a global name.
And that's our successor.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: Could you repeat
why min is not recursive?
Because looking
at this, it looks
like all these smaller
[INAUDIBLE] trees have
[INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Ah, OK.
Sorry.
The question is, why is
the minimum not recursive?
The answer to that
question is not yet clear.
It will have to
do with insertion.
But I think what
exactly this means,
I maybe didn't state
carefully enough.
Every Van Emde Boas
structure has a min--
stores a min.
In that sense, this is done--
that's funny-- not
so recursively.
But every one stores it.
The point is that
this item doesn't
get put into one
of these clusters
recursively-- just the item.
But each of these
has its own min,
which is then not stored
at the next level down.
And each of those has
its own min, which is not
stored at the next level down.
Think of this as kind
of like a little buffer.
The first time I insert
it into the structure,
I just stick it into the min.
I don't touch anything else.
You'll see when we get to
the insertion algorithm.
But it sort of slows
things down from trickling.
AUDIENCE: So putting that min,
is that what prevents from--
ERIK DEMAINE: That will
prevent the insertion
from doing two recursions
instead of one.
So we'll see that in a moment.
At this point, just
successor is very clear.
This would work whether the min
is stored recursively or not.
But we need to know what the
min is of every structure,
and we need to know the
max of every structure.
At this point, you could just
say that min and max could be
copies-- no big deal--
and we'd be happy.
And of course, predecessor
does the same thing.
So the slight cleverness here
is that we use the min here.
This could have been a successor
operation with minus infinity
as the query.
But that would be
two recursions.
We can only afford one.
Fortunately, it's the
min item that we need.
So we're done with successor.
That was the easy case--
or the easy one.
Insert is slightly harder.
Delete is just slightly messier.
It's basically the
same as insert.
So insert-- let me
write the code again.
Insertion also has
two main cases.
There's this case,
and the other case.
But there's no else here.
This happens in both cases.
And then there's some just
annoying little details
at the beginning.
Just like over here, we had to
check for the min specially,
here, we've got to
update the min and max.
And there's a special case,
which I haven't mentioned yet.
v dot min-- special case is,
it will be this value, none,
if the whole structure is empty.
So this is the obvious way to
tell whether a structure is
empty and has no min.
Because if there's
any items in there,
there's going to be
one in the min slot.
So first thing we do is
check, is our structure empty?
If it's empty, the min and the
max become the inserted item.
We're done.
So that's the easy case.
We do not store it
recursively in here.
That's what this means.
This element does not get
stored in any of the clusters.
If it's not the very first
item, or it's not the min item,
then we're going to recursively
insert it into a cluster.
So if we have x in
cluster c, we always
insert index i into cluster
c, except if it's the min.
Now, it could be where a
structure is non-empty.
There is a min item there.
But we are less than the min.
In that case, we're the new
min, and we just swap those.
And now, we have to
recursively insert the old min
into the rest of the structure.
So that's a simple case.
Then we also have
to update v dot max,
just in the obvious way.
This is the easy way to
maintain v dot max in variant,
that is the maximum item.
OK, now we have the two cases.
I mean, this is really
the obvious thing
to get to do insertion.
We have to update the
summary structure, meaning,
if the cluster that we are
inserting into-- cluster c--
is empty, that means it was not
yet in the summary structure.
We need to put it in there.
So we just insert c
into v dot summary--
pretty obvious.
And in all cases, we insert
our item into cluster c.
This looks bad,
however, because there's
two recursions in some cases.
If this if doesn't hold,
it's one recursion.
Everything's fine.
So if the cluster was
already in use, great.
This is one recursion.
This is constant work.
We're done.
The worry is, if the
cluster was empty
before, then this insertion
is a whole recursion.
That's scary, because we can't
afford a second recursion.
But it's all OK.
Because if we do
this recursion, that
means that this cluster
was empty, which means,
in this recursion, we fall
into this very first case.
That structure,
it's min is none.
That's what we just checked for.
If it's none, we do
constant work and stop.
So everything's OK.
If we recursed in the
summary structure,
this recursion will be
a shallow recursion.
It just does one thing.
You could actually put this
code into this if case,
and make this an else case.
That's another way
to write the code.
But this will be a
very short recursion.
So either you just
do this recursion,
which could be
expensive, or you just
do this one, in which case,
we know this one was cheap.
If this happens, we know
this will take constant time.
So in both cases, we
get this recursion--
square root of u plus constant.
And so we get log
log u insertion.
Do you want to see delete?
I mean, it's basically
the same thing.
It's in the notes.
I mean, you do the
obvious thing, which
is, you delete in the cluster.
And then if it became
empty, you also
have to delete in the
summary structure.
So there's, again, a chance
that you do two recursions.
But-- OK, I'm talking about it.
Maybe I'll write a
little bit of the code.
I think I won't
write all the code,
though-- just the main stuff.
So if we want to
delete, then basically,
we delete in cluster c, index i.
And then if the cluster
has become empty
as a result of
that, then we have
to delete cluster c from
the summary structure,
so that our predecessor and
successor queries actually
still work.
OK, so that's the
bulk of the code.
I mean, that's where
the action happens.
And the worry would be,
in this if case, we're
doing two recursive deletes.
The claim is, if we
do this second delete,
which is potentially expensive--
this one was really cheap--
the claim is that emptying
a Van Emde Boas structure
takes constant time--
like, if you're
deleting the last element.
Why?
Because when you're
deleting the last element,
it's in the min right here.
Everything below it-- all
the recursive structures--
will be empty if
there's only one item,
because it will be right here.
And you can check that
from the insertion.
If it was empty, all we did was
change v dot min and v dot max.
So the inverse, which
I want right here,
is just to clear out v
dot min and v dot max.
So if this ends up happening,
this only took constant time.
You don't have to recurse when
you're deleting the last item.
So in either case, you're really
only doing one deep recursion.
So you get the same recurrence,
and you get log log u.
So for the details,
check out the notes.
I want to go to other
perspectives of Van Emde Boas.
This is one way
to think about it.
And amusingly, and this is
probably the most taut way
to do Van Emde Boas.
It's, in CLRS,
described this way,
because in 2001, when
I first came here,
I presented Van Emde Boas like
this in an undergrad algorithms
class with more details.
You guys are grads, so I did
it like three times faster
than I would in 6046.
So now, it's in
textbooks and whatnot.
But this is not
how Van Emde Boas
presented this data
structure-- just out
of historical interest.
This is a way that I believe
was invented by Michael Bender
and Martin Farach-Colton,
who are the co-authors
on "Cache-oblivious B-trees."
And around 2001,
they were looking
at lots of old data structures
and simplifying them.
And I think this is a
very clean, simple way
to think about Van Emde Boas.
But I want to tell you
the other way, which
is the way it originally
appeared in their papers.
There's actually three
papers by van Emde
Boas about this structure.
Many papers appear twice--
once in a conference,
once in a journal--
this one, there's
three relevant papers.
There's conference
version, journal version.
The only weird thing there is
that the conference version
has one author-- van Emde Boas.
The journal version
has three authors--
van Emde Boas,
Kaas, and Zijlstra.
And they're acknowledged
in the conference version,
so I guess they
helped even more.
In particular, they, I think,
implemented this data structure
for the first time.
It's a really easy
data structure
to implement, and very fast.
Then there's a third
paper by van Emde Boas
only in a journal which
improves the space a little bit.
So we'll see a little
bit what that's about.
But what I like about
both of these papers
is they offer a simpler way
to get log log u, successor,
predecessor.
Let's not worry about insertions
and deletions for a little bit,
and take what I'll call
the simple tree view.
So I'm going to draw a picture--
0, 1, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0--
OK.
This is what we call a bit
vector, meaning, here's
item zero, item one, item two.
And here is u minus 1.
And I'll put a 1 if that
element is in my set, and a 0
otherwise.
OK, so one is in the set, nine--
I think-- is in the set,
10, and 15 are in the set.
I kind of want to maintain this.
This is, of course,
easy to maintain
by insertions and deletions.
I just flip a bit on or off.
But I want to be able
to do successor queries.
And if I want the
successor of, say, this 0,
finding the next 1--
I don't want to
have to walk down.
That would take order
u time-- very bad.
So obvious thing to do is
build a tree on this thing.
And I'm going to put in here
the or of the two children.
Every node will store
the or of its children.
And then keep building the tree.
Now we have a binary tree,
with bits on the vertices.
And I claim, if
I want to compute
the successor of this
item, I can do it
in a pretty natural way
in the log log u time.
So keep in mind, this
height here is w--
log u.
So I need to achieve log w.
So of course, you could try
just walking down this tree,
or walking up and
then back down.
That would take order w time.
That's the obvious BST approach.
I want to do log w.
So how do I do it?
I'm going to binary
search on the height.
How could I binary
search on the height?
Well, what I'd really like
to do, in some sense--
if I look at the path of
this node to the route--
where is my red chalk?
So here's the path to the root.
These bits are saying, is
there anybody down here?
That's what the or gives you.
So it's like the
summary structure.
If I want to search for this
guy-- well, if I walked up,
eventually, I find a 1.
And that's when I find
the first nearby element.
Now, in this case it's
not the successor I find.
It's really the
predecessor I found.
When you get to the first one--
the transition from 0 to 1--
you look at your sibling--
the other child of that one.
And down in this subtree, there
will be either the predecessor
or the successor.
In this case, we've
got the predecessor,
because it was to the left.
We take the max
element in there,
and that's the
predecessor of this item.
If instead, we had found
this was our first one,
then we look over
here, take the min--
there's, of course,
nothing here.
But in that situation,
the min over there
would be our successor.
So we can't guarantee
which one we find.
But we will find either the
predecessor or the successor
if we could find the first
transition from 0 to 1.
And we can do that
via binary search,
because this string is monotone.
It's a whole bunch
of zeros for awhile,
and then once you
get a 1, it's going
to continue to be 1,
because those are or.
That one will propagate up.
So this is the new idea to
get log log u, predecessor,
successor is to--
let's say-- any root-to-leaf
path is monotone.
It's 0 for awhile, and
then it becomes 1 forever.
So we should be able to
binary search for the 0
to 1 transition.
And it either looks like
this, or it looks like this.
So our query was somewhere
down here in the 0 part.
I'm assuming that
our query is not a 1.
Otherwise, it's an
immediate 0 to 1 transition.
And that's a special case.
It's easy to deal with.
And then there's
the other tree--
the sibling of x--
the other child of the 1.
And in this case, we
want to take the min.
And that will give us
our successor of x.
And in this case, we want
to take the max over here,
and that will give us
the predecessor of x.
So as long as we have
minimax of subtrees,
this is constant time.
We find either the
predecessor or the successor.
Now, how do we
get the other one?
Pretty easy.
Just store a linked list
of all the items, in order.
So I'm going to store a pointer
from this one to this one,
and vice versa--
and this one or this one.
This is actually really
easy to maintain.
Because when you insert,
if you can compute
the predecessor
and the successor,
you can just stick it
in the linked list.
That's really easy.
We know how to do
that in constant time.
So once you do this, it's
enough to find one of them,
as long as you know
which one it is.
Because then you just
follow a pointer--
either a forward or
a backward pointer--
and you get the other one.
So whichever one you wanted--
you find both the
predecessor and successor
at the cost of
finding either one.
So that's a cute little trick.
This is hard to maintain,
dynamically, at the moment.
But this is, I think,
where the Van Emde Boas
structure came from.
It's nice to think about
it in the tree view.
So we get log log you u,
predecessor, and successor.
I should say what this relies on
is the ability to binary search
on any route-to-node path.
Now, there aren't enough
pointers to do that.
So you have a choice.
Either you realize,
oh, this is a bunch
of bits in a
complete binary tree,
so I can store them
sequentially in array.
And given a particular node
position in that array,
I can compute, what is
the second ancestor,
or the fourth ancestor or
whatever, in constant time.
I just do some arithmetic
and I can compute from here
where to go to there.
It's like the regular old
heaps, but a little bit
embellished, because
you have to divide
by a larger power of two,
not just one of them.
So that's one way to do it.
So in a RAM, that
all works fine.
When van Emde Boas wrote this
paper, though, the RAM didn't--
it kind of existed.
It just wasn't as
well-developed then.
And the hot thing at the
time was the pointer machine,
or I guess at that point, they
called it the Pascal machine,
more or less.
Pascal does have arrays.
And the funny thing is, Van
Emde Boas does use arrays,
but mostly it's pointers.
And you can get rid of the
arrays from their structure.
And essentially, in
the end, Van Emde Boas,
as presented like this,
is in a pointer machine.
Let me tell you a
little bit about that.
So original Van Emde Boas, which
I'll call stratified trees--
that's what he called it--
is basically this tree structure
with a lot more pointers.
So in particular, each leaf--
or every node,
actually, let's say--
stores a pointer to 2
to the ith ancestor,
where i is 0, 1, up to log w.
Because it was the
2 to the-- here.
So once you get the
ancestor immediately
above me, two steps above
me, four steps above me,
eight steps above me,
that's what I really
need to do this binary search.
The first thing I
need is halfway up.
And then if I have
to go down, I'm
going to need a
quarter of the way up.
And if I have to go down, I
want an eighth of the way up.
Whenever I go up, from-- if
I decide, oh, this is a 0.
I've got to go above here.
Then I do the same
thing from here.
I want to go halfway
up from here--
from this node.
So as long as every node knows
how to go up by any power of 2,
we're golden.
We can do a binary search.
The trouble with this
is, it increases space.
This is u log w space, which
is a little bit bigger than u.
And the original van Emde Boas
paper, conference and journal
version, achieves this bound--
not u.
Little historical fun fact--
not terribly well known.
Cool.
So that's stratified trees.
Anything else?
All right.
Stratified tree.
Right.
At this point, we have fast
search, but slow update let.
Me tell you about
updates in a second.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: So once you do binary
search to find the first 1,
how do you walk
back down the tree--
ERIK DEMAINE: Oh,
I didn't mention,
but also, every node
stores min and max.
So that lets me do the
teleportation back down.
Every node knows the min
and the max of its subtree.
Right.
One more thing I was
forgetting here--
when I say, this a lot
of pointers to store.
You can't store them
all in one node.
And in the van Emde Boas
paper, it's stored in an array.
But it doesn't really
need that its an array.
It could just as well
be a linked list.
And that's how you
get pointer machine.
So this could be linked list.
And then this whole thing
works in pointer machine,
which is kind of neat.
And it's a little weird,
because if you used a comparison
pointer machine, where all
you can do is compare items,
there's a lower bound of
log n, because you only
have branching factor constant.
But here, the formulation of
the problem is, when I say,
give me the successor
of this, I actually
give you a pointer to this item.
And then from there, you can
do all this jumping around,
and find your
predecessor or successor.
So in this world, you
need at least u space,
even to be able to
specify the input.
So that's kind of a limitation
of the pointer machine.
And you can actually show
in the pointer machine log,
log u is optimal for any
predecessor data structure
in the pointer machine.
So there's a matching lower
bound log log u in this model.
And you need to use space.
So it's not very exciting.
What we like is the word RAM.
There, we can reduce space to n.
And that's what I want
to do next, I believe--
almost next.
One more mention--
actual stratified trees--
here, we got query
fast, update slow.
Stratified trees actually
do update fast, as well.
Essentially, it's this idea,
plus you don't recursively
store the min, which,
of course, makes
all these bits no
longer accurate,
as it gets much messier.
But in the end, it's doing
exactly the same thing
as this recursion.
In fact, you can
draw the picture.
It is this part up here--
the top half of the tree--
this is summary.
And each of these bottom
halves is a cluster.
And there's root u
clusters down here.
So those are smaller structures.
And there's one root u sized
Van Emde Boas structure, which
is a summary structure.
These bits here is the
bit vector representation
of the summary structures.
It's, is there anyone
in this cluster?
Is there anyone in this
cluster, and so on?
This, of course, also looks
a lot like the Van Emde Boas
layout.
Take a binary tree, cut
it in half, do the top,
recursively do the bottom.
So that's why it was called
the Van Emde Boas layout,
is this picture.
But if you take
this tree structure,
and then you don't
recursively store mins,
and then the bits are not
quite accurate, it's messy.
And so stratified
trees-- you should
try to read the original paper.
It's a mess.
Whereas this code--
pretty clean.
And so once you
say, oh, I'm just
going to store all these
clusters as an array
and not worry about
keeping track of the tree,
it actually gets a lot easier.
And that was the
Bender/Farach-Colton cleaning
up, which never
appeared in print.
But it's appeared in the lecture
notes all over the place--
and now CLRS.
Cool.
I want to tell you
about two more things.
It's actually
going to get easier
the more time we spend
with this data structure.
All right.
Let me draw a box.
At this point, we've seen a
clean way to get Van Emde Boas.
And we've seen a
cute way in a tree
to get search fast,
but update slow.
I want to talk a
little more about that.
Let's suppose I have
this data structure.
It's achieves log w
query, which is fast,
but it only achieves w
update, which is slow.
How do you update the structure?
You update one
bit at the bottom,
and then you've got to update
all the bits up the path.
So you spend w time to
do an update over here.
If updates are slow, I just
want to do less updates.
We have a trick for
doing this, which
is, you put little things
down here of size theta w.
And then only one item
from here gets promoted
into the top structure.
We only end up having n over
w items up here, and about 1
over w as many updates.
If I want to do an
insertion, I do a search here
to figure out which
of these little--
I'll call these "chunks--" which
little chunk it belongs in.
I do an insert there.
If that structure
gets too big-- it's
bigger than, say, 2
times w, or 4 times w,
whatever-- then I'll split it.
And if I delete from something,
and it gets too small,
I'll merge with the
neighbor, or maybe re-split--
just like B-trees.
We've done this
many times, by now.
But only when it
splits, or I do a merge,
do I have to do
an update up here.
Only when the set
of chunks changes do
I need to do a single
insertion or deletion
up here-- or a constant number.
So this update time goes
down by a factor of w.
But I have to pay whatever
the update cost is here.
So what I do with
this data structure?
I don't want use Van
Emde Boas, because this
could be a very big universe.
Who knows what?
I use the binary search tree.
Here, I can afford a
binary search tree,
because then it's only log w.
log w is the bound
we're trying to get.
So you can do these
binary search trees.
It's trivial.
Just do insert, delete, search.
Everything will be log w.
So if I want to do a search,
I search through here, which,
conveniently, is
already fast-- log w--
and then I do a search through
here, which is also log w.
So it's nice and balanced.
Everything's log w.
If I want to do an insertion,
I do an insertion here.
If it splits, I do
an insertion here.
But that order w update
cost, I charge to the order
w updates I would have
had to do in this chunk
before it got split.
So this our good friend
indirection, a technique we
will use over and
over in this class.
It's very helpful when you're
almost at the right bound.
And that's actually in the
follow-up van Emde Boas paper.
A similar indirection
trick is in there.
So we can charge the
order w update in top to--
that's the cost of the update--
to the order w updates
that have actually
been performed in the bottom.
Because when
somebody gets split,
it's nice in its average
state-- or when it gets merged,
it's going to be close
to its average state.
You have to do a lot of
insertions or deletions
to get it out of whack, and
cause a split or a merge.
So-- boom.
This means the
updates become log w.
Searches are also log w.
So we've got Van Emde
Boas again, in a new way.
Bonus points-- if you
take this structure--
even this structure, if we
did it in the array form--
great.
It was order u space.
If we did it with
all these pointers,
and we wanted a pointer
machine data structure,
we needed u log w space.
But this indirection trick, you
can also get rid of the log w
in space factor.
It's a little less obvious.
But you take this--
here, we reduced n
by a factor of w.
You can also reduce
u by a factor of w.
I'll just wave my hands.
That's possible.
So u gets a little bit smaller.
And so when we
pay u log w space,
if you got smaller
by a factor of w,
this basically disappears.
So you get, at
most, order u space.
But order u is not order n.
I want order n space, darn it.
So let's reduce space.
As I said, this is going
to get easier and easier.
By the end, we will have very
little of a data structure.
But still, we'll have log log u.
And you thought this was
easy, but wait, there's more.
Right now, we have two
ways to get log log u--
query and order u space.
There's the one I'm
erasing, and there's
this-- take this tree structure
with the very simple pointers.
Add indirection.
So admittedly, it's more
complicated to implement.
But conceptually,
it's super simple.
It's like, do this
obvious tree binary search
on the level thing.
And then add indirection,
and it fixes all your bounds,
magically.
So conceptually, very simple--
practically, you definitely
want to do this-- much simpler.
Now, what about saving space?
Very simple idea--
which, I think,
again, comes from Michael
Bender and Martin Farach-Colton.
Don't store empty structures.
So in this picture, we had
an array of all the clusters.
But a cluster could be
entirely empty, like this one--
this entirely empty cluster.
Don't store it.
It's a waste.
If you store them all, you're
going to spend order u space.
If you don't store them all--
just don't store
the empty ones--
I claim your order n space.
Done.
So I'm going back to
the structure I erased.
Ignore the tree
perspective for awhile.
Don't store empty clusters.
OK, now, this sounds easy.
But in reality, it's a
little bit more annoying.
Because we wanted to have
an array of clusters.
So we could quickly
find the cluster.
If you store an
array, you're going
to spend at least
square rot of u space.
Because at the very
beginning, you say,
here are my root u clusters.
Now, some of them
might be null pointers.
But I can't afford to store
that entire array of clusters.
So don't use an array.
Use a perfect hash table.
So v dot cluster, instead
of being an array,
is now, let's say, a
dynamic perfect hashing.
And I'm going to use the
version which I did not present.
The version I presented,
which used universal hashing,
was order 1 expected.
But I said that it can be
constant with high probability
per operation.
It's a little bit stronger.
So now, everything's fine.
If I do an index
v dot cluster c,
that's still constant time,
with high probability now.
And I claim this structure
is now order n's space.
Why is it order n's space?
By simple amortization--
charge each table entry in that
hash table to the
min of the cluster.
We're only storing
non-empty ones.
So if one of these guys
exists in the hash table,
we had to store a
pointer to it, then
that means the summary
structure is non-zero.
It means this guy is not empty.
So it has an item in its min.
Charge the space up here to
store the pointer to that min
guy.
Then each item-- each min item--
only gets charged once.
Because it only has one parent
that has a pointer to it.
So you only charge once.
And therefore-- charge
and table entry--
only charge each element once.
And that's all your space.
So it's order n space.
Done.
Kind of crazy.
I guess, if you want, there's
also the pointer to the summary
structure.
You could charge
that to your own min.
And then you're charging twice.
But it's constant per item.
So this is kind of funny.
Again, it doesn't appear in
print anywhere, except maybe
as an exercise in CLRS now.
But you get linear
order n space,
just by adding hashing
in the obvious way.
Now, for whatever reason,
Willard didn't see this,
or wanted to do his
own thing, and so he
found another way to do
order n space log log u query
with hashing.
Well, I guess, also,
you had to think
of it in this simple form.
It's harder to do
this in the tree.
It can be done, I think.
But this is a simpler view
than the tree, I think.
And then boom-- order n space.
But it turns out there's
another way to do it.
This is a completely
different way
to do Van Emde Boas-- actually,
not that completely different.
It's another way to
do this with hashing.
And we're going to start with
what's called x-fast trees,
and then we will modify
it to get y-fast trees.
That's Willard's terminology.
OK, so x-fast trees
is, store this tree,
but don't store the zeros.
So don't store zeros.
Only store the ones in the-- we
call this the simple tree view.
This is why I, in
particular, wanted
to tell you about
the simple tree view,
because it is really
what x fast trees do.
So what do I mean by
only store the ones?
Well, each of these
ones has sort of a name.
What is the name of this item?
Its name is one--
or in other words, 0, 0, 0, 1.
Each of these nodes,
you can think of,
what is the path to get here?
Like, the path to get
to this one is 1, 0, 0.
1 means right.
0 means left.
Those names give you
the binary indicator
of where that node is in
the tree, in some sense.
So store the ones as binary
strings in a hash table--
again, a dynamic
perfect hash table.
Let's say I can get constant
with high probability.
OK.
And if you're a
little concerned--
so what this means--
the ones are exactly
the prefixes of the paths
to each of the items.
This was item one.
And so I want to store this
one, which is empty string,
this one, which is 0, this
one, which is 00, this one,
which is 000, this
one, which is 0001.
So I take 0001, which is
the item I want to store.
And there's all
these prefixes, which
are the items I want to store.
And for this really
to make sense,
you also need the
length of the string.
Strings of different lengths
should be in different worlds.
So the way, actually,
x-fast trees originally
did it in the paper is,
have a different hash
table for strings of
different lengths.
So that's probably an easier
way to think about it.
You store all the items
themselves in a hash table.
You store all the
prefixes of all
but the last bit in a
separate hash table,
all but the last two bits in a
separate hash table, and so on.
Now, what does this let you do?
It lets you do this--
binary search for the
0 to 1 transition.
What we did here was--
I look at the bit, is it 0 or 1?
Instead of doing that, you do
a query into the hash table,
and say, is it in
the hash table?
It's in the hash table
if and only if it is one.
So looking at a bit in
this conceptual tree
is the same thing as
checking for containment
in this hash table.
But now, we don't have to
store the zeros, which is cool.
We can now do search,
predecessor or successor, fast,
in log w time, via
this old thing.
Again, you have to have min
and max pointers, as well.
So in this hash table,
you store the min
and the max of your subtree.
Or actually, from
a 1, you actually
need the max of
the left subtree,
and you need the min
of the right subtree.
But it's a constant amount
of information per thing.
This is not perfect, however,
in that it uses nw space.
And also, updates are slow.
It's order w updates.
But we're almost there.
Because we have fast
queries, slow updates, not
optimal space.
Take this.
Add indirection-- done.
And that's y-fast trees.
y-fast trees-- you
take x-fast trees,
you add this
indirection right here,
and you get log w per
operation order and space.
Of course, this is
a high probability
because we're using hashing.
Because we have a
factor w bad here,
we have factor w bad here.
You divide by w.
You're done.
Up here, you have n over w
space. n over w times w is n.
Queries, just like
before, remain log w.
But now-- boom--
updates, we pay log w
because of the binary search
trees at the bottom,
but pretty cool.
Isn't that neat?
I've never seen this before.
OK, I've seen x-fast
trees and y-fast trees.
But it's really just the same--
we're taking Van Emde Boas,
looking at it in the tree view.
You can see where
Willard got this stuff.
It's like, oh, man I really
want to store all these bits,
but hey, it's way too big.
Just don't store the zeros.
That means we should
use a hash table.
Ah , hash table just gives you
whether the bit is in or out.
Great.
Now use indirection.
And indirection was
already floating around
as a concept at the time--
slightly different parameters.
Van Emde Boas had
his own indirection
to reduce the space
from u times log w to u.
But Willard did it,
and-- boom-- it got down
to n space in this way.
But as you saw, you can also do
it directly to Van Emde Boas.
All these ideas can
be interchanged.
You can combine
any data structure
you want with any
space saving trick
you want, with
indirection, if you
need to, to speed things up
and reduce space a little bit.
So there's many,
many ways to do this.
But in the end, you get
log w per operation,
and order n space.
And that sort of result one.
And it's probably the most
useful predecessor data
structure, in general.
But next time, we'll
see fusion trees, which
are good for when w is huge.